the white house has put out a statement  that coveted cases are being under  reported by hundreds of thousands of  cases  per day  officially there are about a hundred  thousand cases a day and what the white  house says is there are hundreds of  thousands of additional cases every  single day if this is the case this  means two things number one the current  omicron strain  is way more contagious than we think but  number two  it's also way less deadly because if  that many more people are getting it  and we believe we're getting an accurate  reporting of the deaths it means that  the infection fatality rate is  significantly lower